[Music]
so um yeah I want to do a quick gauge of
the room just out of interest of how
much my topic will align to the
audience um who of you are python
developers
here that's a lot some Julia I think as
well that's very oh not so much
are right who are data frame users Ponda
users yeah everybody uses python uses
pandas as well I think there you go hand
in hand anybody here are polish users
already yeah the hands get it more and
more um anybody heard of
polars right and are there some people
who have dabbled in Rust
already right okay cool that's sort of
the topics of today um not R though but
also not Julia sorry about that so my
name is Richie Vin I am the author of
polars and
um I have a background in machine
learning and software development and
since a couple of months I'm also the St
the founder of a PO of a company with
the very original name polars um and we
are going to try to um to make to make
something out of it so today I want to
give a short intro to polers
um a bit about what polar is and what it
makes what makes it different to what we
already have in the landscape I want to
talk about polar Expressions which are
sort of the bread and butter of polars
um I'm going to talk a bit about
optimizations about parallelism and
we're going to uh finish with
plugins um there's also a lot I'm not
going to talk about I'm not going to
talk about how the engine works um and
all the cool stuff we do in there but
that could also be a good topic of a
talk but not not for today so what
polers is polers is sort of a I draw it
but I'm not really good at making this
diagrams what it's sort of a v diagram
you have databases on one side and you
have data data
frames uh typically known in in Python
in R you have data frames on one side
and polus is sort of the Synergy between
both because in my opinion the most data
frames out there were most seen as a
data structure where you have a sort of
a rectangular data structure and you
apply some methods on it right so that's
typically how data frames are being
used for data frames which are focusing
on a single machine we typically used
like this so you have a a
materialization a table with data and a
schema and you apply some optimization
some operation and this operation
immediately materializes this this is
and in pandas is also often is single
treaded so that's why you see this
single CPU core being used
um and in my opinion this is the wrong
way we should look at data frames I
think data frames should be a way of
thinking of data a way of
um um using them in our code but um the
operation you do is is super important
as well that should be part of of the um
part of the the way of working that
should be stored as well we shouldn't
apply the operation immediately no we
should store this operation as a data
structure and this operation actually
this dag of operations this is
are at least as as important as the data
we get out of it as the materialization
so in polos if you do an operation this
is also single threaded we take a schema
and you get um sort of a deck with two
schemas right and if you do another
operation we will extend this deag and
the schemas can change in between right
you can get different outputs of columns
different if you do a um if you parse a
string column into an integer you will
you will go from string to integer so
that will change um but then at the
point you ask this operation to
materialize we take in two steps we take
one we take the deck of computation and
we first apply an
optimization um
because uh now we have an holistic view
of what you want to do you want to read
some data but you only need to those you
only need two out of 10 columns so let's
only read the two columns that are
needed you only need
to uh get uh the first 100,000 rows well
let let's not read all of them we we can
make make these decisions now now we
understand what you want to do but if we
would do things eally we just had to do
it because we first need to read and
then you apply the limit and yeah we
already loaded the data so by just being
lazy waiting a bit we can we can
optimize this cby plan and then
afterwards we go into materialization
and here polars is designed from scratch
um um the second view is that this
material ization is super important to
do performant and to do stuff performant
you have to be close to the metal you
have to be close to memory and to be
close to how you um how you do
parallelism so polar will do this often
completely in parallel and will'll go to
creates efforts to do this
materialization also very fast and what
we what I mean by materialization is
just a step going from query to Output
result um in a nut
we're sort of a database library that
respects 50 years of database design we
looked at the
database uh field and they do a lot of
they've been thinking about this for a
long time and
um it seems that
this not by everyone but but the most
dominant data frame libraries did ignore
this research and just started from
scratch and built methods on top of this
materialization and um yeah so so what
we did is we took the database research
and applied it on data frames and we see
the data frames as a extension of that
and one thing we have is lazy valuation
which gives us query optimization and
this gives you in the order of range 1
to 20 times speed UPS can actually be
much more it depends a bit on how much
we can optimize um we minimize
materialization S as I said if you for
instance do a if we see you do a sort
followed by a limit we can change the
algorithm by a top k for instance and
this saves a lot of materialization
because you don't have to do the whole
sword output and then take the first one
on the drow um yeah the data types are
constructed to amortize access and
allocation cost so we use we adhere to
the arrow memory spec um but we are very
careful in how often we construct those
memory buffers we try to reuse memory
buffers um as a counter point for
instance the current default string type
in pandas are objects just python
objects if you have a python object it's
a heap allocated thing somewhere else if
you want to read the thing you need to
go to memory get the read it and you
have a cach Miss go to the next string
you go somewhere else you have a cach
miss this is 200 times slower just to tr
Verity memory you also have a lot of
wasted you have a lot of memory
fragmentation a lot of wasted space
between memory allocations which you
cannot use um uh so yeah it's it's slow
and it it's
expensive um it's written in Ros so we
have full control over memory we have
full control over treading over over the
stuff that's important to control
performance over when we free memory
when we allocate memory um it's designed
for Effective parallelism there are a
lot of tools that do parallelism in
Python
but I would argue that not everything is
effective if you first need to serialize
a task and you need to send it to
another python process and that python
process need to serialize it there is a
big latency here there's a lot a big
startup cost starting threats is also
pretty costly so if this latency is Big
you can only paralyze large junks of
work which works if you
have easy parallelizable stuff but for
instance if we do a group buy a group
buy needs to do some synchronization
it's not embarrassingly parallel and
when stuff is not embarrassingly
parallel you need to think more about
what data structures you can use how you
can do the parallelism in a way that's
that's
[Music]
um yeah you need to do stuff smarter and
you need to or try to uh reduce
synchronization or try to make stuff
weight free or try to reduce
latencies before you can do useful work
um and it's designed for outof core
processing we're not at the stage we
want to be yet but we already have quite
some support on it out of core means you
can process data sets that are larger
than your Ram size and we do this by
batching in loads and um for instance in
a group by the cardinality of a data set
is if you do a group by you go from n
rows to the amount of groups that's
called cardinality so your cardinality
can be way flow way lower a groupby can
you can do a gr by perfectly in batches
right if the output size fits into
memory you can process this bigger data
set because we don't have to load
everything at once um but we also are
able to spill to dis so if we see that
the output of a groupby still doesn't
fit into memory we we
spill uh cold cold groups groups that
are not used as much we spill to dis and
keep hot groups in memory and then when
we materialize we read them from this
and finish the aggregation um and we
have very tight integration with IO that
means that when we read something we try
to immediately read into our buffer so
we don't have double copies
Etc um so that's sort of in a nutshell
and it's a lot of information um I think
one of the most important things we want
to uh give is the Polish API actually
not the performance not the the Polish
API um is just as important we try to
make stuff predictable
composable and our goal is that you
learn a new expression language and with
this expression language that it's
somewhat akin to learning a programming
language if you learn a programming
language you learn the syntax you learn
the the the vocabulary those are often
not not
so um
not so rich but with let's say the
python vocabulary it fits on a two two
sheets of paper probably um but you can
combine all those keywords and do
anything you want right and with for
loops with indexing with you can do
anything you want and the ID in polers
is if we give you these expressions and
you can apply these Expressions
everywhere you can combine them and do a
lot more than what what's for instance
possible with pandas with pandas it's
super common that you need to go to a
Lambda to a custom to an applied
function because the pandas API doesn't
give you the functionality to do it
without going into python but once you
go into python you are Gil bound because
we have the Gill Global interpal lock
you cannot do any multi trading you need
to materialize you need to materialize
into nony or into you need to
materialize something to give the user
something it can
use so you lose parallelism you lose
you do a lot of expensive
materializations so the goal in polers
is giving you an API so you don't need
to go back to custom lambdas as much as
you needed to um and the the the most
common the the important thing here are
expressions expressions are composable
functions which Tak in a state of a data
frame state of another Series so another
argument and the state of it can take in
the state of a group so if you're in a
group by you have a group state but if
you're not in a group by you don't have
it so it's
optional um and from this state it
produces an output and they are
composable and the inputs can mean
things okay I have for instance I have a
I take column Fu and I take the sum
then um in a in a select we just sum the
column but in a group by we sum the
group right so the input can mean
something different but if we do this
over list elements we sum the list
elements instead of the column or if you
apply this over uh yeah you can also
apply it over literal so what the input
means differs uh depending on the
context
so this
is um what do you want to see here yeah
they are first class citizens that means
you can use expressions in all the
important operations so if you if you
select columns you can use expressions
or if you want to add columns you can
use Expressions but you can also do it
in a group by so you want to group by
this expression so I want to group by
column food * 10 mod
20 um you can use it in aggregations
this is a cool one you can also use it
in in a pivot so here you see we do an
aggregation function and we say we take
the cative sum and then we take only the
head if you want to do something like
this in P you need to apply a Lambda
you need to use a custom function um so
these F first class citizens you can
pass them in many operations and we will
execute them in parallel and fast so
that's sort of the promise um and we are
very serious about using Expressions
actually we're so serious that if we see
that you are you so map elements is um
when you map elements you apply a custom
function a python function to to uh to
every element this will be slow because
you will running a python function and
if we see that you're running a python
function for something you could have
done in polars with an expression we
actually give you an user warning and
say hey we've seen you use this function
this python Lambda you can replace it
with this um with this uh expression and
then it will run vectorized and F and so
yeah and afterwards we replace it and we
get the same output but now fast so it's
pretty cool what we do here we um so
your python converts into bite code and
we deconstructed bite code and say hey
we can do quite
some we can we can recognize some numpy
stuff we can recognize arithmetic uh Etc
so
um thank
you um yeah so so with the API of poers
we want to make a promise that if you
use our AP
idiomatically you will get one thing
that's c-s speed and we're all
accustomed to this right if we use numai
we get C speed that we call this
factorization in numai um you will get
another thing you will get optimizations
and you will get
parallelism and you might get outof core
processing eventually you will get that
we're um we we're building that um and I
want to argue that this is slightly less
than what we're used to with numai with
numai we already got the C performance
but with numai we didn't get any
optimizations numai is eager so if you
do
a any operation multiple
times numai will just execute it and
there's there is no query Optimizer
there's no um so but if you would write
a quer you would write a program in C
the C program would get optimized right
and the optimizer will recognize if you
multip mly column times one it will
Elite this times one because it it
doesn't do anything if you do it in
numai it will happily just multiply
times one because uh
so we of course are not a jit compiler
but you do get optimizations from our
expression engine so it's it's it gets
you more than what you get with normal
vectorization you get query
optimization um and this query
optimization can be worth it because
we're working on Columns of typically
millions of rows if we can Alli some
some operations that were not useful or
not change the result it can uh yeah
save a lot of uh compute um yeah here's
an example query um we scan a pet file
scan means okay read the pet file but
start you when I ask you to to execute
this you need to read this P file but
currently you need to just return me a
dag and from this deck we call this a
lazy frame from this lazy frame you can
continue with your writing your query
and afterwards you apply a filter then
you apply a group by and then you do an
aggregation where we compute the mean
and the um and the
sum and just to give you an an example
of the what optimization can do for you
first we run this query without
optimization and takes 1 7 Seconds you
can see it runs in parallel because the
CPU time is 5.5 seconds so there that
the CPU time is sort of the time the
CPUs have taken if you if they would run
after each other but they are actually
running in the same in the same time so
the wall time that's the one below
that's the that's the time we observe
the time we observed was only 1.7
seconds uh 07 but if you run this query
with optimization It Only Takes Two 230
milliseconds so you get this for free
you don't have to do anything so what
has happened here polus has recognized
that we can apply the filter actually at
the pet file and at pet file there can
be statistics and sometimes we can prove
hey if we apply this filter these
statistics show that
this um this data is not in this row
group we can skip this or we can apply
this filter very soon and don't have to
do the materialization of all the
columns um the same counts for just
selecting The Columns we need we a is
column so we can just select the columns
we need um and that saves a lot of
deserialization a lot of IO reading um
there's also another optimization here
um common sub expression elimination
which I will explain a bit
later here it
is as we see here there is a
um um we apply the mean and the sum of
uh L quantity times extended price and
we do we see that we do this
multiplication twice right so if you
were would be worried about performance
you might have put that computation
first and then did another with columns
um and here it's trivial to see but once
you get into more and more complicated
Expressions it and those things can be
recursive it it gets more complicated to
see where I did double stuff actually
you don't have to worry about this
because poers will recognize it and
poers will recognize um common stop
Expressions we call them um and we will
um pre-compute them cach them and then
cach them for as long as the context
from The withd Columns exist uh so the
multiplication will no there will not be
a redundant M redundant computation here
we do the same with query plans so in a
query plan if you for instance read a
part of a file you do some computation
and then you have a sub tree of your
deck and then you self jooin that then
you would do twice the same right you
would both branches of the join would do
the same operation so we recognize this
and we cach the first join or the first
part and continue from there um you
could do this manually but you don't
have to so the idea is with with
optimizations we take this
responsibility from the programmer there
are also optimizations we can do
internally you cannot do as a user
because you don't have full control over
memory or over um swapping out stuff
here are some of the optimizations we do
these are single pass optimization the
first one is schema checks I love this
one because I really hate it when
my when my pipeline fails 20 minutes in
when I 20 minutes in and I have a I have
a I'm indexing something with a floating
point where should have been an
integer we could have checked that up
front so we try to fail early in polar
um we try to be strict
so uh you will get the hangover up front
instead of uh the the day after so
another one's projection push down it
mean this means we only read The Columns
we need predicate push down means we
apply the filter as soon as possible if
you filter rows before you do a join the
join will be cheaper because you put
less rows in a in in a hash table for
instance
we do some joint Branch reordering
because it's cheaper to only build the
smaller table um we do scan sharing as I
explained if it's the common sub Planet
elimination um and type
coercion yeah we try to make sure that
the types match and otherwise you it's
sort of similar to the schema
checks um and I want to talk a bit today
about not how our engine works but more
how our parallelism work and and a
parallelism is used in in we have two
engines and they actually use the self
same parallelism scheme um and we use a
single tread pool
so in Polish we keep a tread pool alive
and let's say you have three the default
size of your thread pool is the amount
of cores on your uh on your CPU so we my
machine has got 16 cores so it starts
with 16 threads and every every core
will get a dedicated queue a queue of
tasks and on this queue we can publish
tasks and this publishing tasks on the
Queue is very cheap we just uh publish a
function pointer on the on the on the
Queue there's no serialization here
there's no spinning up a thread and the
queue will just keep keep um keep doing
work right if there is available work it
will process it and return the
result um there's no as I said no threat
startup cost staling work does require
some temporary locking so there are some
utex involved um it's there is a slide
overhead so if you're talking about data
frames where you have 100 rows then the
calization the
parallelism might have a little bit
overhead but then we're talking about
counting micro micros seconds anyway um
there it doesn't matter that
much um and we try to minimize this but
there's no contention between threats
and this is important because if you
have more let's say you run start a
threat for every parallel task you have
and you have thousand threads running
then the OS will swap between the
threads and will give try to give every
thread some work to do but this swapping
is super expensive it needs to clear
context uh clear memory um so you don't
want to OS swapping out threats there's
no
contention and we have a
a work a protocol called work stealing
that means that if a tread is finished
or a core is finished with its queue um
it finished all its task it doesn't have
any tasks anymore that's in the second
image it will steal some work from
another queue it will split the work
from another queue take that work and
keep continuing the work and with this
polus is very good at keeping the all
your core saturated with useful work um
the only important part is that we
publish tasks that are some sort of
similar sized right you can imagine if
you have one task that is that takes
100x the time of the other task then
then you would have would be single
treaded so what we try to do is device
the
work make the work divisible in in
smaller
tasks um here is an example of how polar
does
this um this plating of
work if we we create a data frame with
some integers and then we take the
modulo of 1 million so we get 1 million
groups um and then
we um we create some random integers if
we want to compute the unique
integers um in a select context so we
just take one column and we want to
compute the number of unique
elements this number of unique elements
this is a expensive operation we know we
can parallelize this so we parallelize
this over over the three cores we have
but the multiply times two is actually
super cheap so we know that this
multiplication is is not so expensive so
we will actually not paralyze this
multiplication and just do it on a
single column it's not worth doing worth
it doing the um doing the multiplication
the same in a group Buy in a group buy
we depends on group if we have different
group group by strategies but let's say
you have a million groups then you have
a lot of groups group way more groups
than you have
threads we
actually finish the aggregation of every
group in parallel but then it wouldn't
make sense to also parallelize this
nunique within the group right otherwise
you have parallelism on parallelism and
you would you would explode the number
of tasks so at this point the nunique
wouldn't wouldn't split into extra
parallelism because that would create
extra overhead so um and again the
multiplication on the result it's super
cheap so even though we do a group by we
can actually ignore the groups and just
multiply the output of every group
immediately without doing any um
parallelism so it's totally not
important for a user but it's more polar
stries to split the parallelism for you
you don't have to think about you just
write your query um yeah the parallelism
the tread pool is not bound to one query
so there's work schuer um that means you
can use spers behind a work scheduler
like
airflow um or web server because the
tasks just get published on a on a queue
and it will the queue then there will no
be contention will be no contention so
that makes it useful for that and third
the promise you will get performance so
um yeah PO is a factorized query engine
uh is written from scratch in Ross we go
through a lot of effort to have one good
algorithms but also to just Implement
things we want to be as fast as the olab
database engines and that's how serious
we are about um about
performance um so we yeah I'm going to
go a little bit faster because I want to
get to the to the plugins but polers is
super fast um here are some results from
The tpch Benchmark The tpch Benchmark is
a benchmark made for databases it
actually fits databases more than data
frames I would say but poos performs
really good here um you can see more on
a benchmark there's also a benchmark
made by docdb also a super fast engine
where you can also you can see it on
their website PO is also one of the most
performing engines there
um yeah plugins so I talked a bit about
this this parallelism and how you get
this with um um how you get this with
using Expressions
[Music]
but we are we try to be really good in
being composable and being um and not
needing custom python functions but I
know the real world is more isn't per
there there's always something you need
that you cannot do in our API you have
some business logic you do some strange
machine learning which we don't we
cannot support we don't we cannot do
machine we cannot do any I don't know N
Net fitting or something exotic I cannot
even imagine what kind of
scientific formulas there are well
formulas you can actually do pretty good
in in Expressions but there's always
some business logic you cannot do and
you need to refrain to udfs right to to
use the defined functions and the
plugins is a way to do this as if it was
n a native expression so with a plugin
you get native performance you get rust
performance you get native integration
because the plugin will run you can
compile the plugin and you can then
register the plugin to the poers engine
and the pois engine will run the
expression as if it was his own and it
will enable from optimizations it will
it will benefit from parallelism and it
will be
fast
um and so you have no Gill for instance
and as an example I want to build a pck
letin converter so pck lein is a silly
language where you take the first letter
of a word you swap it you put it that at
the end so Pig if you take the first
letter P it's going to be i p and then
you always end with i to make it sort of
uh um what PIR Pirates do so Pig Leen
would become egg pie adding
lay easy
right
okay now let me find my
mouse
so and let me find oh this is hard um
yeah five minutes we can do this
um I'm going to go a little bit so so
this is some Ros code that takes a
a string and converts it to to Pig ltin
you just have to believe me this is how
you can write that function you can
write this function in Rust and then you
can expose this function in in an
expression you create your pig leify
expression it takes as input a series
and it takes as input some quarks
keyword arguments from python which get
automatically deserialized so you can
create a struct and put anything in
there and we will deserialize this
keyword arguments from python into the
struct in Rust and then you can use it
and here we apply this
function um and then the only magic here
is we say okay this is going to be a
polus expression and the output type
will be utf8 you can also provide a
function here which will say what the
output type will be for Bas it's
important that we know the output type
because we need to do optimizations to
be able to do that we need to know what
we have
right can I zoom in man you ask a lot
sorry um can I zoom in I don't
know
ah I don't
know not within the time I
have I'm going to explain it a little
bit I'm going to walk you through it so
you can compile this
expression um I pre-compiled it but um
at that point you can just
um create a clause
language where you say okay this
language has got a piig lendify
expression you wrap it and then you this
is the only boilerplate you need I'm
going to share my slides afterwards
sorry for the and this is the only thing
you need and then it you can compile it
and then we go into
the um
into the python world back to the python
World let me get my
mouse
so here we have a
um we're back in in Python world we have
a jupyter notebook is this
readable is I can zoom in here better I
think here's Control Plus
right no
help
me yeah
okay did it make a difference yeah did
it oh okay I'm gonna read some uh pet
file and I'm going to read the comments
and I'm going
to um create many columns with some text
just to get get a lot of data
points so here it is now we have 16
columns with 5 million strings and
strings are very expensive data types
um and it means we have 80 million data
points and we want to make this big
ladin converter and the naive way to do
this would do this would be doing this
in Python right you would write a python
function
um and then you use so in polers you can
select columns with an expression so we
select all columns that start with the
col commment um name and then we apply
this
function and then we output it so let
me
make it a bit more interesting
by this is
challenging here we can see on the top
you see my CPU you see my memory usage
and let's run this thing and I don't
know why this thing will be slow I don't
I know why that is but there's also some
stack behavior in memory
um it seems that because of the Gill in
the
parallelism um every column gets a bit
of work and builds its thing but just
when the last column finish it it can re
re it can release the memory again of
the temporary state so actually because
of the Python Gill locking it seems that
that other every time another column
gets work to do but yeah it was slow it
took a lot of memory
um it took 22 seconds right A Better Way
would be writing a polus expression we
can just write a polus expression so we
slid and then so we first take the
first um if we have Pi we slide so we
get I and then we put the first letter
on
um at the at the end and then we end
with i right is this readable so this is
a polar expression this would be a
better way so this should be
bigger bigger I cannot so this would be
faster well it's finished it's a lot
faster we saw there was a lot of
paralyzation we didn't saw any memory
bump um and the wall time was 800
milliseconds but we want to build the
fastest Big L converter we have so we
use the polus plugins um and to use the
polus plugin we can just import our
library Pig Lettin that's it and now
it's a available as a pi name space on
an expression and we can run this
thing and this took 330 milliseconds so
we had got a speed up of
2.5 by so we go from 22 to 800
milliseconds to uh 350 milliseconds so
the speed ups are are very clear the the
memory consumption is a lot better and
parallelism is very good so in this case
you could have done it with an
expression but there's also a lot of
once you do more exotic stuff or your
own business logic you going to build
hash Maps I don't know then it's going
to be for instance if you do anything um
cumulative which we then it's going to
be hard with the data frame right to to
to express
cumulative if we don't support it so we
do support a cumulative sum but if you
have a cumulative I don't know what kind
of statistic cumulative media or um then
it's going to be uh I don't I don't know
I'm I'm making something up then it's
going to be harder so I um this is what
I wanted to show with Expressions I'm
going to go slightly back to the
presentation to have my last
words ah it's not
that it's not that much oh man
it's also going in the wrong
direction well thank
you there there's one thing I want to
ask if you want to try out polis and you
learning we have a very active Discord
with people a lot of with people helping
each other out a lot so if you want to
say hi in Discord um and learn more be
welcome
so thank you Richie for your talk um
right now we're going to take some
questions uh well as I am the moderator
today uh I get the chance to have the
first question yeah uh so I was actually
wondering how you get got started on
Polar right so you've taught us a lot
about how polers works but how did you
actually end up there yeah well it's a a
story of changing goals I would say I
uh I was dabbing in Russ and I uh needed
to join
a uh two I built something in a in a web
server and I needed to join two files
which normally I would do with
pandas but there wasn't a data frame
library in Ross I thought oh let's
import the data frame Library being
accustomed to the python landscape and
then there was any wasn't anything so I
thought how hard can it be to R join so
did some research it was super slow did
some Benchmark with P said okay this is
really slow okay how can I make it a bit
faster and and as I went I just you you
start learning about joints about
relational stuff you learn about
databases and I thought at a point I
wanted to make it lazy and at that point
I really started coming up with the with
the query
[Music]
engine uh stuff and that's sort of akin
to what an interpreter is and when that
started rolling Yeah the more I learned
the more I learned about what kind of
tool stuff databases did
and that I thought okay we need to do
this differently um
but it started as a hobby project and it
was a hobby project for certainly for a
year it wasn't I didn't think any
serious anything series of it back in
the day completely escalated yeah yeah
yeah yeah but the last two years at a
point it we're like
Okay um
I think we can you once while you learn
more you think hey okay we I think we
can make stuff better because it it
doesn't make much
sense
how we first tried to do the Ponda API
for instance and that became super hard
because it's super inconsistent to
predict what it will output and then we
want we once you do want to do anything
in parallel the P API didn't make that
easy if you want to do stuff
lazy it just made stuff hard and the
more we the further we got we thought
okay why not start from scratch and
build something that we think is the
best way to do it um and it became more
opinionated and I thought okay this is
how I think you should work with
data not that we're there yet but we we
wanted to start from scratch and
just have a clean slate and think
logically how would you use
what would data frames look like if we
want to use all the threats on your
machine and you want to use utilize your
Hardware from scratch um while learning
from what the database engines did yeah
awesome thanks so are there any
questions in the room over here so we've
got a
[Music]
microphone over
here
awesome uh um thank you for the talk
Richie um I had a question about the uh
the choice of of R um R sorry uh looking
back do you think the the the uh the
choice you made was a deliberate Choice
say compared to C++ or do you think if
you didn't have rust and you would you
would have to do it in C++ or a
different language how would you benefit
or uh how much did you benefit from R uh
rust sorry rust so the choice wasn't
deliberate because I just was dabbling
dabbing in Rust at the
time if Russ wasn't there and
I I deliberately built a data frame
Library I don't think I would have built
one because I but let's say I wanted to
build one I think C++ would be a good
choice though I think Russ is a better
choice uh currently with what we have
because Russ gives the Russ has got a
concept called borrow checking and
borrow checking it's got some guarantees
that you cannot one you cannot um get
sack fults get get undefined Behavior
bad behavior if you don't if you use the
safe language which we don't always use
because we care about performance but
the amount of unsafe is way less than
the amount of safe code and so that
makes it a lot easier but another thing
that makes it super I think the B
checker guarantees that the same
guarantees about memory also give you
guarantees about Deadlocks about um
about uh multi- threading and multi
threading
is is insanely hard debugging
multi-threaded code and um just having
raise conditions and once you start
building a complicated engine and you
have all kinds of stuff
happening um stuff gets really hard and
I know from a story that Firefox tried
this in C++ with the c engine and they
failed I believe three times and they
were able to complete the refactor with
Ross because in Ross it doesn't compile
if you if you send something mutable to
another thread and both threads can
mutate it for instance it just doesn't
compile and you get it explodes in your
face up front and then you have to
rethink Your
Design but it will prevent you from
building something something
unmaintainable in the end so I think if
you if you go multi- threadit I think
Russ is a a very good choice yeah thank
you but it was not deliberate okay right
yeah you can throw it to me are there
any more questions all right so I'm
going to take two more um and then we're
going to have to uh wrap up because
there are other sessions waiting as
well yeah there it
goes first throw of the day sorry guys
is this is this working yeah uh is there
are there any like existing or planned
uh features that support uh like
distributed like
multi-worker processing uh is there any
desire to like compete with like spark
on that front or no um yes and so we we
started a company so our goal for polars
is Empower your laptop Empower your
single machine and we think vertical
scaling is is going to be way more
important I think up to a terabyte I
think in the future you you distribute
it it will be hard to beat uh vertical
scaling I
think um but we are also going to make a
pol Cloud
solution and with this we want to make
some sort of a hybrid where we I don't
think the spark solution with with
always going horizontal is the optimal I
think there should be some hybrid where
we can say okay we want vertically scale
but this in this gr it's probably useful
to batch do some batch work but that's
something we didn't start yet we still
have to figure out and um so I cannot
comment too much on it but yeah there
are some
goals thank you so there's a question in
the back um not sure if your aim is any
good last question all
right want to find their next okay still
works yes there we go um thank you
Richie for the talk I was wondering uh
there are all kind of new features
coming up or already existing later
version of python like creating new uh
interpreters with our own Gill yeah and
um would that affect and have you
thought about that in polers and are you
also involved in let's say steering uh
new developments in
Python uh no it shouldn't matter much
for polers because we don't want you to
use python we want you to use Python we
want you to use Python but we don't want
you to use Python functions to to use
polers because even when there is uh a
gill per thread you're still running
python
code so use expressions or use plugins
um so use Python to I think python is a
great duct tape language use Python to
get into C or to get into rust or to get
into C++ if you do if you do anything
performance critical I think you should
use python as a duct tape language um
yeah awesome thank you thank you last
round of applause for
[Applause]
[Music]
Richie